hello and welcome to the 20th PHP basic
tutorial this tutorial we're gonna cover
writing and appending to a file very
similar right we'll just overwrite
everything like it'll write every let's
say you have a file that already exists
and it has a few lines in it and use the
write function it's just going to
overwrite that whereas a pen will just
kind of it will do that it will append
into the file and won't delete what was
maybe already there so if you were
having like a log file you would want to
use like append so anyway let's talk
about that so why don't we just go ahead
and work that with the script here and
we're gonna go ahead and get rid of this
that's why we just cleaning it up a
little bit so we're not too confused but
we'll use this mission data and store
that data so now what we want to do is I
changed my mind let's we just want to
echo that but then we just want to
there
and just because I'm a little tired let
me make sure that works still we need to
just like mess it up touch me okay it
does work that's good so we'll come back
over here and now what we want to do is
save the text like let's say if text is
entered so if not empty what do we want
to do so let's make some space and we're
going to say we're gonna specify save
file and that's going to be able to use
app open and then in here there's two
parameters the first parameter that
you're going to specify this name of the
file if the file already exists great if
it doesn't exist PHP will just make the
file actually I suppose it's probably
see that makes the file but PHP is going
to tell C to go ahead and make the file
so we're going to just call this file
saved on text and then in here you
specify what you want to do are you
gonna read or are you gonna write or
even append in this case I think we
should just depend or we'll go ahead and
write so then now that you specified
that if the file doesn't exist this line
that we've written right now will create
that file the next thing we want to do
is let's go ahead and write to that file
so let's do F right and again this will
take two parameters the first one is
going to be where are we writing to and
then what shall we write and in this
case let's go ahead and write hello and
then it's always a good idea to go ahead
and append a new line which is backslash
and so . plus a backslash in colon and
that's what we're gonna write now as
always with opening and writing files
and such you always want to end with
closed otherwise if you come back to
attempt to edit the file later it might
restrict you it might say this is open
you know else
so let's save that and we'll upload this
to our server yes and we'll go ahead and
all we're going to need to specify what
we want to close and in this case of
course we're going to close save files
save that re-upload so we'll go ahead
and bring that up into our text editor
and you can see it already saved hello
this is because we ran out here so as
you can see we've already got
hello text is saved here upon the
uploading of this PHP script and that is
because we actually have you know what
it's saving the file is something we've
you know predefined but what if we want
to write to this file how about we write
text to that file so save this we upload
it and we'll pop over here and sample
tags misspelled knuckleballs save and
now let's view edit this
yes there we go and so you can see it's
been rewritten to display sample text
now like I was saying that's what right
is going to do it's going to overwrite
the stuff that's already there and put
the new data in but what if we want to
append it so so the way that we can
append data is instead of opening it
with the intention to write let's open
it with the intention to append
otherwise everything stays the same
you're still F writing you're still
putting the text you're still saving it
so we'll save that throw it up to the
server and this time let's write more
sample tags and hopefully it will edit
correctly you edit this card download a
file anew and then here we see it's
actually appended our sample text or
some Mapple text and then so on so you
can continue writing to this file so
that's it for writing and appending to a
file as always thank you for watching
and until next time